so we created this really convenient
environment but we neglected the fact
that a lot of that inconvenience is
actually what turns us at a cellular
level you need to move you need to
express in order to be healthy so so
easy ways to do that I would say how to
integrate Fitness into who you are as a
person as opposed to it being like this
compartmentalized thing that you do
three days a week you know your whole
day is Fitness take walking meetings
you're getting natural sunlight walking
is a really beautiful way to help with
consolidation of memories so if you're
working on like a hard problem of some
sort or just work in general walking is
one of the greatest things you can do
for yourself sunlight I would say is
probably the First Sunlight nutrition
and then Community I would say like the
base fundamentals like you need to eat
and you need sunlight next is community
period there's nothing it's not money
it's not it's like you need Community
meaning makes money you don't make money
without Community you don't make money
alone